hello everyone
and welcome back to the end game class
as always my name is caleb denby
and tonight i want to take you through
some more practical
rook end games so we've done a lot
a lot a lot of work on theoretical rook
end games
and a lot of you know four versus three
right we have this outside past pawn
idea
but i wanted to take it back a few steps
and specifically talk about this idea
of rook activity and king activity in
rook and games so i think it's really
important to talk about because it's
great to have this theoretical
understanding
of these different structures and talk
about the various plans
that you can enact there but there are
going to be a lot of end games that have
many many pawns on the board and it's
going to be
a little bit more about what you can do
with the pieces
rather than what plans you can uh can
construct
so let's let's talk about it let's talk
about activity i want to flip on
over here to the board it is no longer
the russian championship
we have to get rid of that all right and
to start with here we're not going to
look at this
that's for later we're going to look at
a game between solomon floor
and milan vidmar so of course floor
of course is a very famous player from
back in the day i myself have done a
game review
on it where i sat on the floor the
entire time
but let's talk about this game uh i
don't care about any of this because
this is not the end game it's not what
i'm here to discuss
and wait hold on all right we have
knight c6
with knight take on c6 huh rook c8
rook c5 okay b takes c6 we have arrived
we've arrived at the end game here we
are
uh so what's going on what's going on in
this
position well we have one two three
four five six pawns for black one two
three four
five six pawns for white so it's clear
that the material is even now of course
though
the position is not even uh it's far
from
equal here of course white is going to
be the the player with the advantage
why is that well we have a difference
this rook is passive
and this rook is active and just for
those of you who don't don't know what
this means
the white rook is spending its time
making threats attacking the pawn on c6
and the black rook is doomed to be
defensive or or passive it's working
behind its own pawns
trying to keep white from invading so
how can we turn this slight advantage uh
both in sort of structure and activity
into
uh sort of a winning advantage well the
first step is
is probably apparent to most of you
we're not really at the point where we
can try and turn this activity into any
kind of advantage
we of course first need to include the
kings
kings are going to be very very valuable
in any sort of
uh simplistic end game where there's
only one or two pieces left on the board
they don't have to worry about getting
checkmated as much so they can
participate in the battle
so we start with the move king e2 black
of course is going to follow suit with
king e7
we have king d3 now king d6
and the move king d4 here would be
absolutely fine
but we actually see white first include
rook a5
rook a8 and then uh king to d4
okay so what is what is going on here
right we we have the kings in the
position and let's put one more
more one more move on the board for
black
and that move is f5 okay
so first things first there is one more
structural move
that that i sort of want to include
before we we take a step back
and talk about uh how to approach this
position
so priority number one is always making
sure
we have a good grip on things and white
does this with b4
just making sure that these two
weaknesses are not going to be able to
advance forward any further
and now we see black insert rook b8 just
a tempo move
on the b pawn a3 brick back to a8
okay so now we have this position so
uh obviously white is going to be better
here we have the active rook
we have two targets to attack and we
have our opponent sort of in a more
passive
looking position but how do we continue
here how do we turn this
into a position that we can start to try
to win so i want to
open this one up to the chat room i'm
curious what your guys's
ideas are here and maybe we can talk
about some of those ideas
why some are correct and why maybe some
are not correct
white rook is getting passive so i i
disagree so just because the rook looks
a little bit stuck in front of the own
in front of its own pawns does not mean
it's passive it's
serving very active roles here and can
easily switch over
to the c uh the c5 square and attack
either of these pawns it can also come
back into the game
if necessary
okay so there's a few ideas here's a few
ideas
so idea number one is to push through
with a4
and b5 just keeping the fight on the
queen side
and coming for coming for black over
here
okay idea number two seems to be to try
and gain space
on the king's side it's like h4 moves
like f4 are being suggested
i haven't seen anyone say g4
specifically but i think that's
sort of in line with what you guys are
saying right
and then we have one more idea making an
appearance here
making an appearance and that is the
idea of e4
so there's also some really good ideas
being
you know sort of typed out in actual
words in the chat room as well
so one thing most people seem to agree
on is that
we need to do something on the king's
side it's not enough
to try to win on the queen's side we
have this very famous principle the
principle
of two weaknesses right it's not enough
to win on one side of the board
we have to sort of stretch our opponent
a little bit more thin
by creating threats on both sides of the
board that way
they won't be able to handle all of our
threats and we will win
the game where we are having some
differences
is how to go about doing that before i
get to that i want to talk about a4 b5
so it is important to take a look at
these kinds of ideas
and see why they don't work so a4 in
this case is just tactically
wrong due to the move rook b8 you have
to go king c3
now after rook b6 this rook is both
passive
well sorry both defensive but no longer
passive because it is actively
attacking this pawn uh on b4 and white's
advantage is sort of completely
nullified here
a4 just gives up the grip on the dark
squares and allows black to get active
so a4 doesn't work but
a4 is is a pretty good idea it's it's
worth thinking about at least
because if black doesn't have this idea
of rook b8 like let's say nothing
happens
then b5 i think is going to be a pretty
good advantage for
what you do have to worry about c5 check
but
at the end of the day um is this winning
i think so i don't know maybe probably i
it's okay but a4 it's sort of a move
point because rook v8 is is here
so good idea to think about but with
that out of the way
what does that mean well that means we
have no way through on the queen side
which means we do have to turn our
attention to the king's side of the
board
and as i was saying we do have some
differences here in how to actually go
about
uh doing that so a lot of people were
saying
sort of this vague idea we want to gain
space
on the king's side and that's a
perfectly fine thing
uh fine thing to say wanting to gain
space
is perfectly reasonable but the problem
is
there's no real comfortable way to do
that right like you can play h4
and maybe you can argue this has
improved your position
but you're not really going to play h5
uh you can play f4 but then this is
perhaps
giving yourself uh your own weakness
your own backward pawn to worry about
and lastly i just don't really think g4
is the way to go again
for the reason being that you're giving
yourself sort of a weakness that you
have to keep track of here
and in the meantime what are you going
to do with this extra space are you
actually creating threats
by having this extra space i'm not so
sure are you creating targets things
you know in roads for your king i'm not
so sure
so the correct idea as mentioned by some
in the chat is to actually play e4
so why is this correct why is this the
the path forward
for floor here well the idea is
we have this active rook here on a5
attacking this pawn on a6
easily able to attack the pawn on c6 as
well
but our king for the moment has been
blocked
so with e4 we are granting our king more
access to the king's side of the board
where it can poke around
make some more threats we're also aiming
to open up this
fifth rank for the rook uh just sort of
increasing the activity
and allowing it to access the king's
side
but the the most important idea here for
white is this idea of
finding a way for the king to contribute
right it's not enough
for this rook alone to be very active we
need the king in the game as well
if we are to win so e4 great move
by floor we have f takes c4
in the game black is trying to trade off
as many pawns as possible
try and simplify things a little bit uh
there's there's really not much other
choice here otherwise
white is going to take on d5 and then
win the game
so f takes c4 f takes c4 d takes e4
and king takes e4 uh
and now black passes with rook to uh
work to a7 so how do we continue now
how do we continue now
we gave ourselves great mobility with
our king
right great mobility uh what are we
going to do
with said mobility
what are we going to do
king back to d4 repeating the position
so yeah now that we have this mobility
uh the chat room is
is along the right thinking we want to
induce a weakness
on the king side or start making threats
on this side of the board so king f4 is
absolutely the way to start doing that
and with king f4 white is making a very
very very distinct threat here
and that is to go king g5
and king h6 uh and now
quite simply this this is too much for
for black to have to deal with we have
our two weaknesses right we
turned h7 into a weakness because we can
attack it and now black is going to very
much be struggling
to stay in this game for example if
black were to pass with king e7 you can
just increase our pressure here
black has nothing better than to repeat
and at the end of the day uh i think we
can actually now
just break through with with a4 and be
fine now this idea of getting active
it's not really going to be good
because our king is attacking the second
weakness over here
on h7 and i think white should be easily
winning here with two past pawns
uh okay so of course
you know vidmar pretty good chess player
not going to allow that so we see
h6 uh but the problem for black is that
the further up
the board these pawns move the the
easier they can be attacked
so our priority now is to
force a weakness on the king's side for
the moment
our king is blocked all squares defended
on the fifth rank
he's holding the line so how do we
continue
by forcing through another weakness how
do we go here
what if black tried rook fade check uh
assuming your f7
so yeah this is playable but um
yeah i think maybe white would just
retreat
and you have to come back to defend your
pawn then i'll just come up and pour it
and you have the the same problems if
you go here now then i'll i'll take your
pawn
yeah erika seven's a good idea
and yeah the chat is right right on the
money here as well you want to force a
weakness with these pawns
and the way to do that is to use your
own pawn sort of as as a lever here
going h4h5 forcing these pawns forward
and forcing one of them to be left
behind uh king e6 was black's choice in
the game
now we see king g4 just preparing h5 or
k8
and finally h5 g5 does come so
we've done great so far we've made a lot
of progress it might not look at
it might not look like it because our
opponent is kind of just passing back
and forth and then
playing playing the required moves when
they need to but we've actually made a
ton of progress compared to the starting
position
what we've done is given our king
multiple inroads into the position
we can threaten to come this way with f5
g6 and we can threaten to come this way
with c5 b6 and it's going to be
difficult for black to keep both of
those under control
additionally we've opened up our rooks
access along the fifth rank so it can
swing into the game
whenever possible and lastly we've given
ourselves
a strong h5 pawn and an h6 pawn
that is quite weak and notably if this
h6 pawn falls
it's a very short road to victory with
h6h788 so a lot of progress
has been made in the past five moves so
i'm going to go back and go through
those again
because it's really important to
understand how we got here
we started our thinking process here
after the move rook a8
we have this active rook but our king's
not participating so e4
is the way to go why is e4 the way to go
well
with this pawn back on e3 it's simply
too difficult to get this king anywhere
like you're not
going on some marathon journey these
things are
are kind of just too slow you don't
really achieve anything by taking these
these this long long journey over to h4
so
we go e4 in order to give our king a
path uh
to the king's side and sort of widen the
beach head
is divered ski if you read davoretsky's
endgame manual
he says this so many times so what does
he mean by that
i honestly don't understand the metaphor
but the point now
is that we have widened the the front
that black needs to defend
black still needs to keep control over
c5 and c6
now he also has to worry about this side
of the board as well and that
is the mechanism that stretches black's
forces too thin
and allows white to win the game so then
we come over to king side
and use this path in to create a
weakness over here
on h6 okay
so what to do now well now we should
bring our king back to the center of
course where it's the most active
uh floor actually starts with the move
g3 which is just a nice little subtlety
here
uh regarding the the f4 square as well
keeping control of
some dark squares and getting off the
the second rank
uh name namely though the main point is
just to control
uh the f4 square it could be relevant in
some lines
but not the most important move of all
time so rook a7 king f3 we're okay eight
black is sort of doomed to this
passivity for now we get king e4
rook back to a7 uh and our king is now
centralized
so first they repeat the position uh and
then
floor finds the path forward so we
have improved our position pretty much
to the maximum here right we
drew black's pawns forward into a more
vulnerable vulnerable position
we gave our king two paths that our
opponent has to look
out for has to keep track of they have
three weaknesses now that to
to to look for a weakness on the queen
side and a weakness on the king's side
so how do we actually break through how
do we pull forward here
so okay this g3 move i should mention is
not exactly the signage rule it's sort
of the anti-steinens rule
for those who don't know steinen's rule
is that the pawn
is best placed on its starting square
because you can then choose to move it
one square
or two squares depending on what the
situation calls for
and this lets you win a lot of mutual
zug's funks in this case
black was not in zug's black which is
passing so g3
not really the same idea uh in this case
it's more for the squares that the pawn
controls
is my argument
but yeah easily confused ideas
sorry to go on that tangent there but uh
anyways
the the chat has the right idea here um
the idea
is is simply rookie five check uh and
the point now
is that again we have two different
paths in
and after rookie five the black king can
really only stop us
from doing one of those paths so rookie
five check
is correct and in the game vidmar shows
uh king to d6 let's talk a little bit
though about king to f6
and what would happen here so really
importantly here
i think white actually does have a few
paths forward
but uh
yeah i think g4 is is going to be the
idea
sorry i had to remember what was going
on after king f6
uh but yeah g4 is going to be really
nice black has nothing better
than to pass and then after this
we can uh play rook c5
or ga5 and invade with the king this is
the point we
we do this little funny maneuver to gain
a tempo get our wreck out of the way
and then we'll invade on uh on on the
on the queen's side here so king f6 does
in fact allow the king into the queen
side
and allows white to win uh to win the
game
so i just had to remember how the
details worked out there so once again
maybe g4 isn't even required you can
probably just do this
and king d4 this is the winning idea
here for white i think
it's going to include g4 to stop king f5
but not
entirely necessary uh so king f6
allows the king in on the queen's side
now king d6 as played in the game
is perhaps uh you know a pretty good
attempt as well
uh it turns out that white could have
just simply won with king f7 i believe
after rick f7 check we do have king g6
and this king and pawn on game is
hopelessly lost so white could have
invaded
but floor found a different path forward
now with rook to e8
keeping the king cut along this file
and the one idea for black to try to
break free
unfortunately for vidmar is just not
working
c5 seems to be breaking loose
from white's grip on the position and
perhaps would be
but white again has multiple paths
forward not rook c8 the arrow
that you just saw was incorrect by the
way but b takes c5 and rookie six
is one path forward that would be quite
good but
uh floor accurately calculated that rook
to d8 check is quite simply winning upon
the natural king to c7 loses to rook h8
when after really any move let's say
c takes b4 we have check
take take and then
everybody calculated everybody
calculated i know you guys you would
never
skimp out on calculating this everybody
calculated
all the way all the way i know you
you made it this far to equals bishop
when
when of course the pawn on a2
cannot queen so rook d8 check
actually a pretty sick move because
flora had to calculate out this
silly king and pawn end game where after
takes
we can check and take and win the game
because we're just so fast with our king
um sir do you check king c6
vidmar did spot the idea and now rook c8
check rook takes c5
simply picks up this pawn and now it's
quite clear that this king is going to
invade
rook h7 was played rookie 5 king
c6 rookie six check and now king f5
and after rook f7 rook f6 vidmar went
ahead
and resigned so how quickly things go
wrong right how quickly things go wrong
after we played e4 was there no drawing
resource for vidmar so i sort of did
this on purpose
i didn't talk a whole lot about black's
defensive opportunities in the game
vidmar sort of put up the bare minimum
resistance just passing back and forth
allowing white
to to do all these these active ideas so
now we're going to take a second look at
this end game and rather than look at it
from the attacking side which my opinion
might be the easier side
we're going to take a look at it from
the defensive side and see if we can
find
some way to to fight back a little bit
more but before we do that let's review
just a little bit how we got here from
the attacking side
so we started once again in this
position
we needed to widen the area
that black had to to worry about right
now he only worries about the queen side
we have to make him worry about the
queen's the king's side as well so
e4 uh is the move in the game now our
king
has a great path to attack these pawns
over here rook a7
we go h6 is forced to stop us
from invading and now we use our h pawn
as a little bit of a lever
to pry open some weaknesses here now we
re-centralize our king and repeat moves
one time in our rookie five check is
nice to force our opponent to pick a
side
it goes to f6 then we can invade on the
queen side
and if they go to d6 then we see in the
game
king f5 would be winning but rookie 8
check
is the accurate move by floor taking
advantage of this check idea
when the end game wins and then we
simply pick up this pawn and invade with
our king and the game's over
just like that the game's over easy
enough
so so so so
chat room let's do it let's do it with
the other side now
let's do it with the other side what's
going on
in this position for black i'm curious
if anybody
can come up with an idea to escape
this bind we are so so sad that we are
forced to be passive forever and ever
because we've seen that this passive
defense is not enough for black white is
able to make threats on the king's side
stretch our forces then and as magnus
carlsen said there are no fortresses
in chess this is definitely not one of
those non-existent fortresses
so how how do we break free
h4h5 was the most counterintuitive okay
let me talk about that one more time
while you guys are thinking here so
manny is talking about when the pawns
were on h6 and g6
and white played h4 h5 the key point
there
is that g6 is blocking the white king's
inroad to the position
on f5 so we go h4 h5 to draw this pawn
forward
and now our king has access to another
path inward
through the f5 square also very
importantly h5 is going to be a strong
pawn
quite close to queen if the h6 pawn ever
falls so that's
the nuance with that maneuver there
okay everybody's saying rook b8 i don't
know if you guys paid attention but
that's what happened in the game
and then white defended the pawn and
then black had to come back because this
pawn was hanging
okay everybody everybody catch that so
not rook b8 that ain't it boss that
ain't it
after rook v8 rook b6 so this is
actually a worse setup for black
um i mentioned this idea um if
a4 here then black goes rook b8 rook b6
and the point now is that the black rook
defends the pawns and actively attacks
the pawn on b4
however sorry in this position if we go
rook b6
then our rook does not actively attack a
weakness because this pawn is quite
simply defended
and now it's a worse version of this
passive defense
because after i play the move h4 for
example
um and sorry let's not even play h let's
play rook a4
rook a5
and then play move right you just get
zucked
right this work cannot pass anymore and
then you get busted so that's not active
that's not active so we need to do
better
sacrifice the a pawn to activate the
rook so we're going to sacrifice
something to activate the rook
but it might not be material it might
not be material
so harry bowman seems to be on top of
things tonight
seems to be on top of things
so yeah we'd love to activate this rook
somehow we want to get this rook in the
game
on some sort of opening file but we
can't for the moment because our apon
dies and that's super sad
i like my a pawn i don't want him to die
so
the thing that we're sacrificing is
going to be our king activity
so the very very counter-intuitive move
king c7
uh is actually going to be correct here
and the point is
in rook and in king rook and pawn end
games
uh often times the rook activity is a
lot more important than
king activity i'm going to say that
again a lot of the time
rook acts a lot of the time rook
activity is more important than king
activity and that's the case here
so rather than have the king sort of
battling the king
and the rook uh battling the rook
in a sense the king passively stopping
white from invading and we're passively
stopping white sort from invading
we sort of do two jobs at once with the
king
on c7 white can try to invade with king
c5
and now we go king b7 and the key point
here
is that no matter what white does we are
now
free from our prison on a7 and
a8 we can bring the rook into the game
and fight back
uh rather actively and i think this is
the best way
for black to continue in the game by the
way this is a position in varetsky's
endgame manual and i just wanted to
mention
i didn't come up with this king c7 king
b7 id on my own
this is included in that analysis there
so just
wanted to be clear on that not trying to
take credit for
this brilliant idea here
exquisite corpse is doing some math in
the chat
king controls eight squares max rook can
control 16
i disagree i disagree
with your numbers
then he corrected the 15. i still
disagree
isn't it 14 we're getting a little bit
beside the point here but
the point is rook activity more
important than king activity so black
allows
white's king to enter the position and
dooms his own king to passivity
in this case in order to activate the
rook on the e
file so white can and probably should
continue
to invade with something like king to d6
and now there are actually a variety of
ways for black
to come back into the game so i
mentioned rookie eight so let's start
with this one
rookie eight is perhaps the the simplest
idea
now rook a3 is going to be the point
for white
and i i want to sort of uh start my
my disclaimers now so here are my
disclaimers right
in general rook activity is more
important than king activity but that
being said
whenever you do something like this and
allow the white king to invade
there are going to be a lot of specifics
that you have to worry about
so in this instance the specifics do
actually work out for black
this is going to be a good drawing
attempt for black
but it's not to me it's not to say that
this is like the the blanket rule that
you should always follow
who cares if the king invades just
activate your rook you'll be fine
because there are some very tangible
threats that white has
or that black has to deal with here and
you do have to walk a rather thin line
in order to avoid falling into some of
these
some of these ideas so black to move
here what do you guys want to do
in the chat room here what do you guys
want to do
okay everybody hates their pawns
everybody wants to sacrifice one pawn or
the other
king v6 has also been suggested
so it's important to understand what
white is
uh what white is doing so what is what
is white doing
and what are we doing about it
sit on this position king b6 king b7 so
this is the the thing to look out for
here uh white is not
passing the time here white uh with this
active active king
is now able to just make threats on on
the queen site that you have to look out
for so something like king b6
may be as playable but you do have to be
very cautious about moves like rook c3
when all of a sudden this guy is
attacked two times
and defended once and don't even think
about playing rook c8 get get out of my
chat room if you want to play rook c8
here
we're not playing passively anymore
we're getting active
so you do have to be just a little bit
careful just a little bit
cautious of these kinds of things and by
the way
if you're saying f4 i just want to
mention if you wanted to play f4
you should do it here so this is the
slightly more complex way
that black could uh could play for some
some active play
uh and i was going to go over this
secondly but
playing f4 sort of a move later is just
a worse version the idea of f4 isn't
really to invade with the rook
it's to uh push the spawn off the board
and
sort of threaten to make a queen and
find active play
this way so f4 is is not the worst idea
ever but in this case it doesn't make
as much sense uh okay
so what else i'll talk about f4 here
as well though with the idea of invading
with the rook but but what other ideas
okay everybody everybody just wants to
sacrifice a pawn here everybody's saying
yeah
i don't care get rid of these pawns uh
so let's talk about it let's talk about
f4 here uh i do think f4
is the the better way forward uh
doubling white's pawns
and then d4 i think the the d5 pawn
uh can be quite strong in many instances
so we
tend to want to keep this this past pawn
if we can so let's say f4 and then
rook e2 what's going on here what's
going on here
well in this instance white is actually
able to make use of this f pawn with
move g4
right with the move g4 we can take a
pawn on h2 but this extra pawn isn't
really going to make any difference here
right all of a sudden we may live to
regret allowing our opponent's king to
d6
when it's a short step away from
allowing the set pawn to promote
f4 doesn't quite cut it so then let's go
back to d4 maybe d4
is a better way of doing things and
perhaps it is but in this case
after rookie 2 i think white can just
simply continue with rook c3
and while we are going to be gaining
some pawns back here
uh i'm not so sure that we're entirely
happy with
the end result right this past d-pawn
is going to be a little bit scary going
to be a little bit scary and there's a
lot of work to be done
before this this position is is over is
white winning here
i don't know rook end games are hard but
definitely not the best idea
for black to to aim for this uh you
should be very very scared
if you get into this position uh okay
now are there any nuances where we can
do it better let's
take a look maybe rook d2 is a good idea
to come after this guy
but there are a couple uh different ways
forward here
for example rook c4 is putting black
into a little bit of a zug's long right
tough to make any moves
can't move the king i'll take your guy
can't move this guy
i'll take your guy and we sort of
transpose
and there's just simply not not much
else to do here if you
take g2 and try to take h2 instead of a2
uh now the problem you run into is that
uh this a pawn is going to be pretty
relevant
on a4 we can make another pass pawn on
the king's side and again
or start the queen side and again white
is going to be better so
f4 and d4 good ideas but they should
have been played here
if you wanted to do this you should have
played f4 here and made use of this
d-pawn
rather than going for this active rock
so
what else what else
what else to do harry bowman
likes king d6 so let me
go back a little bit so yeah king b6 uh
you guys have to have yet to answer me
what are you doing about rook c3 white
is making a very distinct threat here
you have to be a bit cautious
so the problem with those types of pond
moves is they they aren't
really passes right they aren't really
passes like
you know you move a pawn then white
passes with king d7 then you move
another pawn
and white passes king d6 and eventually
you run out of pawn moves
now play f4
okay i'll take
what's different here what's so
different
i'm not sure
with king b5 to follow
i don't i don't understand the point
don't understand the point
so yeah maybe you can do something like
this again with some d4 ideas
but yeah i don't think it's it's the the
principled way for it so
as some people in the chat are saying g5
uh
is a really great idea here and what's
the point well the point is actually
sort of a
sort of multi-purpose in this case
number one
we want to play f4 and activate with our
rook
coming in to e2 but we're not so happy
about giving
white this super strong past f pawn like
g4 f5 that
that comes really really quickly so
black just plays g5
with the idea of f4 to follow now
excuse me if we do see the move rook c3
uh perhaps f4 is going to be good enough
but i think there's actually a second
idea here for black
in the form of g4 surprise idea
g4 and the point now is that if you take
here
i will take here
and you are not really making a past
pawn i'm going to take on f3 next
if you take me then we are getting into
pretty simplified territory here
and sorry maybe you lose a rook if you
do that so rook h2
or it takes a2 or it takes h7
and white is not going to win this game
uh it's just
too simplified one of these pawns is
going to drop off the board
white black will be able to take the b
pawn in exchange
or at least get that pawn off the board
and it's just going to be
a dead draw okay so g4
surprise idea surprise idea
so is white powerless no white can play
the move f4
and try to keep things closed but now
black is still able to find
activity with the move rook e4
rook takes on c6
and then i think rotates b4 is the idea
but maybe even or takes e3 is still
quite
strong here yeah let's let's say rotate
c3
and we're getting into some things that
are very similar
where white just cannot keep everything
together
and black is approaching a draw so g4
really
really cool idea g5 g4 not necessarily
finding activity by immediately breaking
into the second rank
but finding activity by activating on
the e4 square
so for example f4 rookie 4 a3
even and then rook c4 is going to be
a good idea for black and sorry yeah so
rook takes c6 maybe we should actually
be taking on
on b4 uh my memory is
is failing me here i just remember that
like a3 is the best try
for white but then this loses or sorry
maybe it doesn't lose but it's quite bad
in light of rook
to c4 so rookie four really cool idea
really cool idea
what if not f4 uh well
then what and then what i was looking at
rook c6 but rotake c3
is is good enough for um
for white and if we just pass here
and then uh perhaps any number of things
but
maybe simplest is to take here or even
just push with with h5
just push with h5 as well
all right so what was the point of this
end game
well number one we saw really great
winning technique
by solomon floor in the game
uh where he constricts the position
and then plays e4 widening the fronts
makes threats on the queen's side gives
his king an inroad
and then invades on one side or the
other
and is able to win the game on the other
hand
we could have seen from black a really
instructive idea
of freeing up the rook by allowing the
enemy king to invade pretty
counter-intuitive stuff
but good enough for a draw in this case
activating the rock
and once again by the way those of you
who are fans of f4 i think this is the
best
moment to uh to do it here if e takes f4
then you can do something like d4 and
you know it is a little bit scary to be
sacrificing pawns like this
but uh you get this nice d pawn in
return
and what's the evaluation of this
position
uh i honestly don't know for certain but
uh this would be a good
sort of drawing idea or a drawing
attempt for
black maybe not kv6 maybe something like
something crazy like a5 or c5
but you get the point you get the black
plays for counter play and gets active
this is the point of this end game so
rookie 8
and then we get this nice g5 g4 idea
with the point being we want to open up
this e4 square
and come over to c4 or take on b4 so
questions on this
end game
questions on this end game
king takes white pawn i do not accept
your question
this is not jeopardy questions come
in the form of questions not in the form
of answers
yeah d3 immediately i don't think quite
works i think there's a king d7 move
there
and then you lose lose the pawn d2 or d3
good question though good question
actually no
it wasn't a good question you phrased it
in the form of an answer ridiculous
how would i do it if i played this uh
well
i i'd like to think i would play like
king c7 king b7
but i don't know this is the best way to
play so
in an ideal world i would do this but
in the world we live in maybe i would
just lose horribly that sounds about
right
is it a drawn position computer
evaluation so
uh in devretsky's endgame manual he
evaluates it as a
draw but this is not really the type of
position that you can just ask a
computer
say hey computer tell me is it a win or
a draw and it'll tell you
you sort of have to do a lot of work
which thankfully
deforeski has has done for me in many of
these cases
all right well we only got to this one
um
one end game here tonight but we only
have a few minutes left so i think
rather than try
and cram in a whole second end game i am
just going to call it here a little bit
early gives us some more time to do
analyze your games
on twitch right after this so thank you
guys so much for watching
uh hopefully you found this end game at
least a little bit instructive
this idea of retreating the king back to
b7 i
i think is really counter-intuitive at
least it was to me
but it activates that rook it gets that
rook active and that's enough
for black to hold on here so uh
once again thank you guys so much for
watching as always my name is caleb
denby
and i will see you next time as
i flip away goodbye
you